yeah thank you very much apologies in
advance if I made the less sense than
normal I'm a little bit sick today but
we'll get through it I was interested
when the organizers of the conference
asked me to to suggest a talk for
consideration because we've been talking
more and more about julia in my field
and we're wondering whether it's whether
we should push the students into using
it or not and so they asked me to come
here and give a talk about julia 4 as an
introductory level and I was very
curious to see who would show up for the
talk if indeed anyone especially on a
Saturday morning so just a little bit of
background so that you know whether you
should pay attention to my opinions on
this or not given your own backgrounds I
have actually been programming since the
80s I've been using the web or I've been
using the internet since before the web
started I've been involved in a lot of
open source projects using Linux kernels
since like 93 94 type time so I have a
long background in this kind of area and
I'm a bit of an early adopter so I think
we should make that clear that this is
early adoption type stuff I work here in
Berlin as a computational neuroscientist
and this field involves a lot of diverse
skills so you need to be able to develop
models very quickly you're trying to
figure things out whether you're playing
with data or making a model to to
explain a biological system you want it
to be incorporated very quickly and you
want to try out ideas very quickly but
at the same time you have a problem that
everything in the brain just scales
massively so if your problem looks
promising if your idea looks promising
that you need in some way to scale up
your code massively and you need to do
these massive massive simulations at
some point in addition to that there's
an error a question of numerical
reliability of your calculations so up
until a few years ago many people in our
field used MATLAB then there was a
change to Python with with a sort of a
new generation of scientists in the
fields we held off from Python for a
long time because of questions about
numerical reliability and stuff of the
language but ultimately numpy was just
too tempting and so everyone everyone
got on board eventually
the problem there though is about the
scalability and we'll come back to that
when I worked a couple of years ago on
my PhD just to give you an idea of the
scale
I was simulating typically systems with
ten thousand neurons and five million
synapses and each of these things
neurons and synapses are represented by
differential equations so you need to
solve this differential equation on
every single time step of your
simulation so that's like five million
differential equations every time step
so this massive scale and I know that
the code I wrote at the time so I
started in Python and then I had to at
some point translate it to open CL to
run on a GPU and this this code scaled
easily to a hundred thousand neurons and
five hundred million synapses a we
haven't pushed it beyond that we didn't
we didn't see the need but it's just to
give you an idea of the scale here but
we always want the the precision so when
you're doing this many calculations if
there's like a minor problem in your
code where you're not quite you're
rounding a little bit incorrectly this
is going to scale up and up and up over
repetitions if you do the same thing a
hundred thousand times or ten to the
nine times or ten to the twelve times
you're going to see a very huge
divergence in the outcome eventually and
this is a huge problem in numerical
computing and so this is something that
we all are probably aware of in this
room but you have to be very careful of
I started using julia two years ago I'm
a user I'm not a core developer I'm here
to talk from a user's perspective and
just for this particular audience I
teach actually the advanced scientific
computing course using Python at both
the Humboldt and technical universities
so I do have some qualifications in the
field of Python as well so Julia is a
it's an interpreted language it was
invented I think in 2009 the guys got
together writing at first and the first
official release was in 2012 so this was
version 2.1 that went up on github so
that's very very new it's produced by a
group at MIT and they have a rather long
history of developing tools on they were
paid on DARPA contracts on on various
Department of Energy contracts in the US
to develop tools to allow numerical
programming to scale up and so the idea
was to retrofit things like
parallelization onto existing languages
at the time and they had some success
but they also thought to themselves yeah
but this is not quite the right way to
do it and we need to think about this
some more it is this is important at the
general-purpose programming language
like Python so you can do anything in it
but the numerical computing is at its
core in general data scientists people
who do numerical computing where
performance is an issue should be
interested in Julia compared to MATLAB
which would be one of the big
competitors it's so many orders of
magnitude faster at this point if you're
a Python user and you're already pushing
the bounds of Python using siphon it's
probably of interest to you and for me
personally it's this fast route from
prototyping too high to poor high
performance implementation that was
particularly attractive and also I mean
I did say I am an early adopter so if
you want a new toy to play with it is
also interesting from that point of view
for this particular audience I think
it's important to note that
syntactically it's very easy to learn
from Python so the syntax is quite
similar I have to admit I would say the
same thing to a MATLAB audience so the
numerical processing the the equation
writing is closer to MATLAB in some ways
but the programming side is closer to
Python in in look-and-feel
so it should be quite learn about for
most of you the big convinced er for me
was that you can use all your existing
Python libraries in it so there's a
there's a library called PI call and
it's just a single commands and then you
can call any of your Python libraries I
don't think I would have made the jump
without that because it allows you to
learn the new language while maintaining
your existing tools so I personally I
found that very important the
development cycle is pretty similar to
Python in terms of how you interact with
it I'll show you some examples in a few
minutes but in terms of what type of
editor you use to write your code this
is not something on the on the level of
complexity of C or Java it's much more
interactive like Python the absolutely
astonishing thing is that it runs
see like speeds it really really runs as
fast as see for most situations which is
really incredible and then for me again
personally because I like
parallelization I do problems that
benefit from parallelization it's built
into the core of the language I don't
have any good examples of that for you
today but it's really it's in there in
the design of the language which is very
important rather than as a retrofit or
as a library add-on so I'm just going to
give you an overview of from a
programmers point of view from an
abstract point of view of the language
and then I'm going to switch to actually
how you run us and I've got an I Python
type notebook to show you some some
example cases and how the other language
works in that so these guys sat down and
they decided we're going to develop a
new language they said we've got these
huge numerical problems and we want to
we want to get it accurate and we want
it to be scalable and then there were
some other things which came into play
so one thing is that I suspect most of
the people at this conference are doing
the kind of development where it's
highly interactive this is a data
conference so a lot of you are dealing
with data and so you want to load the
data into something like a data frame a
panda and you want to play with it and
you're not entirely sure what the
results are going to be until you've
finished your analysis at which point
you do not typically write an
application to redo the analysis you've
finished it at that point so unless
you're developing applications a lot of
the development nowadays is interactive
and so you've got some kind of read eval
print loop where you're typing stuff in
or you're copying and pasting it in or
or you're importing it and you you try
out your code and then you make some
modifications and you try it again this
is a very very different development
style from hardcore software engineering
where you plan it out for weeks and then
you write it for months
and then you finally try us bearing in
mind that they do do testing along the
way they tried to learn from existing
languages so Python was revolutionary
when it came around came along and it
still changes the way we compute today
so Python showed us it was one of the
first languages which really showed us
that dynamically typed interpreted
languages can be extremely useful in
your
day to day confusing and also it can
scale up to making follow-up full-blown
applications so I mean red hats really
transformed the scene when they started
using Python for all of the scripting in
the in Red Hat Linux whatever it is 15
years ago or so and this really showed
us that hey you know it doesn't have to
be as complicated as Perl or whatever
and yet it can do absolutely everything
you want to do and computers are finally
powerful enough to use this interpreted
language and you don't have to worry
about compiling it for five hours on one
computer in order to root runners on any
computer so this is really nice and
there's something that languages can
certainly learn from nowadays the other
thing is that rapid prototyping and a
low barrier to entry are very important
language characteristics nowadays so
we're we're in a kind of a framework
where people do agile programming and so
on they want to see the results quickly
and they don't want to spend a lot of
time figuring out the minor nuances of
the language and whether you use a bit
shift or whether you use some kind of
other function can you gain the last
little nuance of speed out of your
system so they really just want to be
able to sit down at the computer and
address the problem you're thinking
about rather than sitting down and
saying well my programming language
allows me to do X Y and Zed and then
there's the final thing is what happens
when you need to scale things up so it's
great having these these dynamically
typed interpreted languages but they
don't always scale so well so the
typical solution is that you use two
languages and I've done this many of my
friends have done this you write your
code your scientific type code in python
matlab mathematica or s s plus whatever
you want and you do your investigatory
work and you do your prototype
development in this language you find
that yeah we've got something that looks
pretty interesting here now I'd really
like to prove that it works so I need to
scale it up in some way and you go back
and you rewrite all of your code or at
least the important parts of it in C
Fortran in my case I wrote an open CL
some of the people in this room maybe
are using siphon or something like that
in order to get the performance which
allows you to really really scale up
your
um they I don't remember what I was
gonna say about that question this is
just a huge development overhead okay
what I was going to say is that there's
only in large companies where this step
is somewhat massaged where you have
engineers in the company who take the
prototype code and they rewrite it for
you
so I have friends in some of the bigger
companies and they you know the kind of
google deepmind and the type and in
these companies it's true that they have
an engineer who will rewrite the code
but this is extremely rare and even then
there's a time overhead in all of this
that the engineer does not turn around
and produce the C code the next day for
you it'll take him a few weeks or even a
few months to rewrite us so tight time
time is an issue here you've gone and
you've spent all your time writing here
and then you need to translate this so
how is Giulia solution to all of this
so in technical terms it's a dynamically
typed language still like Python but
with optional types and I'm going to go
through each of these these points in
turn just to define them it's got
built-in types that are equivalent to
user-defined types and I'll tell you why
that's important it's just in time
compiled using the LLVM Suites its
utilizes something that the developers
effectively coined the phrase and stand
call dynamic a multiple dispatch and
this is where most of the speed comes
from it has full major programming
capabilities and you can call C and
Fortran libraries natively which is very
important for some of the numerical
computing so what does it mean to say
that it's a dynamical language with
optional typing so Python as I said is a
is a dynamically typed language that
means that types are interpreted at
runtime and they can change during the
runtime of the of the system so your
variable can change type while you're
running the system and so python the
interpreter needs to check from time to
time to make sure that it's still the
type that it thinks it was and all of
this checking is an overhead in the
system at runtime C on the other hand is
statically typed so it's fixed at
compile time
this is great because there's no more
checking after that can of course lead
to
is buffer overflows and stuff like that
but that's another issue but the the
real catch with the c1 is that this
needs to annotate the code really slows
down the the actual coding process so
you're writing C and you need to
constantly think about your types you're
writing in Python you don't need to
think so much about your types you sorta
do need to know that you're running the
right function on the right variable but
apart from that it's hopefully taking
taking care of it for you so you've got
this speed trade-off here with types and
in Julia it's basically optional the
types are there under the hood but you
don't have to define them and they can
change dynamically at runtime what's
interesting is that the use of these
types is largely not required to obtain
the performance boosts so you don't need
to go to the trouble of coding them in
so typically you don't it will help a
little bit in previous versions of the
code of the the system it helped a lot
more but they've they've optimized the
compiler system now and they've ironed
out the bugs and then so it's it's much
it's it's very handy now and it
interprets the types correctly and
basically you don't need to do as much
type checking because of this the
feature which I'll mention in a couple
of slides called multiple dispatch so at
various parts of the code the
interpreter is better able to interpret
what are to predict what the types will
be and then you need less checks so at
that point the types become important
for basically saying which code gets
called at which point by saying that
well we're going to do an addition here
on integers or we're going to do
something here on my super privates new
data type which I've just invented and
you'll do you'll do different operations
depending on which one you're calling it
on for like real language aficionados I
just have two very brief comments one is
that types are optional as I said but
you can it does the default type
promotion which happens in most
languages so if you add an integer and a
float you do still typically get a float
it's it's reinterpreted as a float so
the integer gets promoted to a float
before the addition happens most year
languages including C do this behind the
scenes what's interesting
that you can redefine these types and
you can extend them for these promotions
and you can extend them for your own
types but it's only for the the real
people who are going to go really into
the detail the most important thing is
that most of the core is written in
julia at this point they originally
started in c in other languages to
bootstrap it but at this point most of
its written in in julia which means that
they have a real incentive to make sure
that the built-in language types have
the same speed as the user-defined ones
because if you start defining them in
your julia code and it's somehow slower
so most languages if you define a type
in the in the in yourself in the
language it's slower than an int or
float well in this case no they have the
same priority in the language and there
it's it's optimized for handling
user-defined effectively and since the
native ones are effectively user-defined
they're all equal LLVM is at the core of
the language or sorry at the LLVM is the
compiler effectively here so it's a
compiler infrastructure project julia
what it does and this is a great way to
bootstrap a language julia generates
intermediate representation code and
then LLVM takes it it optimizes it and
then it compiles it forever whatever the
whole system is and LLVM has so many
front-ends and backends at this point
that you can you can run it on so many
systems then finally the output the
compiled output row executes on the on
the host system and this process is
extremely quick LLVM was designed for
run time optimization of code actually
back when it started and what I find
nice is that it allows you to dive down
and look at the intermediate
representation so you can look in fact
at the code that you've generated and
there are some tools for that and you
can see whether you're actually going to
make a difference by changing if I write
a plus V versus a plus B plus C what
what happens in the in the intermediate
representation and you can see pretty
quickly why one is faster than the other
or why a certain loop style might be
faster
okay multiple dispatch I don't want to
go into too much detail
but it is the core feature of the
language the nicest description I found
of it online was that it's overloaded
functions with late binding if you don't
want to know about this just don't
listen for this one slide
they basic class-based object-oriented
programming typically it's dynamic so
it's at runtime that it's interpreted
and it's single dispatch so if you've
got a variable a depending on the class
type of a you get a different function
call so the function call is defined
within the class so at runtime you
figure out what a is and after you know
what a is you know which function you're
calling in typical function overloading
in languages like C it's static multiple
dispatch so static because it's done as
interpretation time and it depends then
on what the parameters here which
function gets calls so you can overload
the function it C basically does it that
it's it's dynamic so it's at runtime and
it's depending on the types of all of
the parameters so every single parameter
that you put in there all of them are
then check to see what type they are and
the actual function implementation that
gets called depends on what the types of
those are and that's actually where the
speed comes from in the city in the
system because once you're within the
function
the interpreter or the compiler knows
what the data types are from the
parameters that were passed to us and it
allows it to massively optimize for that
macros are a feature of the language I
called it meta programming so this is is
a bit like decorators in Python they'll
allow automated code generation which is
pretty nice and it also allows for some
kind of nice optimizations so sometimes
if you're solving a function or whatever
it can be better to have the actual
version of the function hard-coded so
like x squared plus X cubed and so on
you need to know these powers this is
faster than doing a general solution to
the problem and so by using macros
rather than writing a generic function
this can be done as at compile time and
then you get huge speed speed ups and
finally I said that C and Fortran can be
called natively so most of you know that
most of the numerical libraries are
written in C and Fortran that we use
today
this gives us huge speed and also
reliability because they've been checked
so many times you call them using a
function called C Carl
Clark here is the function that's called
their return type as an int 32 and
there's no parameters passed in this
example the just-in-time generated
instructions are identical to those
produced by a C compiler so there should
be no overhead here in making this call
if you're writing it for your own
libraries it has to be from a shared
library but the hard thing is that
you're responsible for type
compatibility and I should also say that
you don't have access to header files
and stuff like that from this system so
it's only through the shared library
interface so it's a little bit more
tricky so now we're going to go quickly
through an example of some stuff of how
to interact with the language so you can
download it here from Julia Lang org the
documentation is all online a year ago I
spent a lot of time on the forums
complaining about the quality but it's
really really very good now the forum is
extremely active with the Lassa with a
lot of users so it's on Google Groups
and just look for Julia or Julia users
there's four ways of interacting with
the language you can run it in the
command line you can use a raffle you
can use an i - like notebook so jupiter
notebooks or you can run it in in assam
with a plugin called Juno so I'll just I
have some screenshots so you can run it
on the command line like Python you run
Julia and then the file name and it does
some kind of output for you end of story
the read eval print loop which many of
you will be familiar with you just type
in your code you run Julia it's got a
nice logo if you if you run it like this
or you can disable that you type in your
code the thing runs and this is actually
my way of interacting with it most of
the time I can copy and paste my code
into it I can import code from a source
file and it just loads it so like the
the what is that symbol % run symbol in
in ipython jupiter notebooks which my
example is in it's called i Julie a
rather than ipython and finally this is
going to be very nice but it's not quite
there yet I would say previously they
were using light tables some
might have heard of that as a new new
development environment what's cool is
that you run it here in the text editor
and these little tick marks mean that
you ran that line of code and when you
run the line of code it tells you what
the output is so this a ran four by four
gives you a four by four array of
float64 S which is two-dimensional and
if you click on the little arrow thing
beside that you can actually see the
elements of it so it's very like some of
the kind of Mathematica type interfaces
which I think is going to be very nice
you can print out the council down here
you can print your graph here but I have
to say I played with it last week and I
was not overly enamored with it just yet
the light table implementation was
beautiful but they ran into some
development hurdles with it they've
switched to awesome only a couple of
months ago and it's just not quite
finished yet but if you come to it in
two or three months time it'll probably
be working very well i am i put in a
special slide for this before i show you
the example you can forget about
indentation there's a Python audience
you start things with words like
function and if and you end them with
ends and indentation is irrelevant here
it was beautiful briefly in Python and I
have to say I got over it pretty quickly
I use IDs and stuff and I just I want
the code to be indented by the way but
just for readability not for not for use
so okay the example I have here let's
just clear these selves where we go I'll
put Q okay so it's quite simple I'm just
like gonna run through it and we have
five minutes left so that's perfect so
you can declare a variable a and give it
a value ten you can give a different one
B and it's fifteen point three is this
is large enough for do I need to zoom it
more okay that's getting better I could
also go fullscreen
you can do another variable so you do a
sum notice that that's int int float
idea was not a problem here there are
very very simple mathematical functions
like exponential built in we can use
functions like linspace to to initialize
the variables we have functions like
ones which give you a vector of ones and
a random array of four by four by four
random array where all the elements here
are random numbers this is just to give
you a quick example I'm gonna put this
online there should be nothing shocking
here to anyone who does programming so
the first thing it for this audience is
that array indexing is from one and not
from zero so if I do from zero there's
an error at the end of the array is
addressed by end and unfortunately the
minus one indexing does not work that
was a bit of a shame you can do various
skipping through the indexing so this is
like from one to end in steps or two of
that a array and we see that we get the
first element followed by the third one
here and we go down in this way we go
that to the third one here in 0.6 and
0.37 which is down here
there are boolean types obviously like I
said the types are dynamic and I didn't
have to tell it it was a boolean I can
run a while loop based on that boolean
with various logic inside so there's a
while there's a counter plus equals
works which it doesn't in every language
there's an if statement and so on I can
do this kind of indexing in a in a for
loop so for all of the elements in a
works as well and I just print them out
here and I have a so this is kind of
MATLAB style I would say this this loop
here for I is 1 to the length of D so
for all of the elements I do some modulo
arithmetic here just for fun but I'm
really just showing you that all of
these language elements exist here this
is because you know you kind of wonder
these things when you come to a new
language so we can declare a function
which I called foo and it prints out two
things that prints out a statement here
and it prints out the argument value of
the thing you pass to
so a a had value 18 and the type of a is
in 64 on my machine could be in 32 on a
different machine now this is the first
example of multiple dispatch I can write
a version of foo which only accepts
floats and so this is the notation here
and it's actually the the same function
or it's the same internal contents but
this one only accepts floats and now
I've got a function with two methods
called foo so there's an online help
system like in ipython and so on so you
can just use the question mark so for
the print statement it gives a nice
output for my foo command it'll just
give the example headers here for that
for the two so there's a generic version
and there's one specified for float64
and so if I call it on a and B so I call
it on a which add value 18 and it works
I call it on B and it says oh that was a
float because actually I didn't realize
I changed the text inside slightly so
it's the float version of the of the
function call and we passed because we
passed to the float so there's a totally
different function implementation here
functions are passed by reference so the
calls are almost cost-free but there are
some rules then about whether the
variable gets changed once you're inside
the function or not so in general it's
supposed to not but there are certain
ways of addressing elements of an array
where it does so here I passed at the
variable 18 it added a took 45 to it and
in the function the value was 63 but
when I come back out the value is still
18 you D here was it was a vector it
gets modified in the function but when
you get out of the function it's not now
if I change the addressing and I use
this element wise addressing of the
array
I can suddenly change the elements of an
array type variable so here I passed as
this array or this vector it gets
changed in the function and outside the
changes are maintained so this is a way
of accessing the very the variables in
such a way that they get they get
permanently changed this is about
mutability but
sickly this worked because this was an
array and if I look here at this type of
the D variable and I write a new
function bar so I don't know if you
notice the first one was barren the
second one was bar 2 so now I'm going to
overload bar effectively and I'm gonna
give a specific version which only takes
this data type and all it's going to do
is it's going to call bar 2 on that
phone that data on that parameter
there's various functions like methods
to see what the methods are some bar now
has two versions and bar two has just
one it takes any variable type and now
if I passage that vector we see that we
passed it this value this vector here it
gets modified inside and the changes are
maintained even though we call the bar
function and not the bar to function and
if we do it with a which was like an int
the changes are not maintained so that's
important to note so the last real thing
I wanted to show you is that you can
call Python libraries so I'm using PI
plus here there's a an error because
something is overloaded but that's fine
and if I want to plot stuff I have
nothing pretty to plot I'm just gonna
plot a sinus and here it comes
somewhere there we go so the plotting so
this is the full matplotlib you have
access to all of matplotlib in here and
yeah the only other thing i wanted to
say is that data frames exist in Giulia
so you can use them like pandas but I
don't think like I don't have a nice
example here I just showed that I can
read in some data and I and I plotted a
sense you can you can vary use various
functions to access the elements but
until you're actually using a data frame
or whatever it's kind of pointless it's
just to show that you can see that the
variables have these names X 1 X 2 X 3
and so on so let me just switch back to
my slides really briefly so julia is
working pretty well there is 493
contributors to the core as of this week
there's 966 registered packages I knew
people would want to see a benchmark at
some point
so this is the benchmark that they the
guys who developed it publish one here
are 10 to the 0 is C speed so if you
implement various functions in C Julia
is over here it's clustered around C
type speeds Fortran is typically lower
or faster than C but with one outlier
where it's slower and python is this
line over here so it's it's roughly one
order of magnitude slower than C on most
of these kind of typical programming
functions so just to summarize Julia is
quick to write it's fast to run
it's a general-purpose programming
language it's designed from the ground
up for numerical computing with parallel
processing and easy scalability and all
of your existing Python tools should
work with it and so with that I'd like
to thank the organizers for inviting me
I'd like to thank all of you for
listening for your time and I'm really
grateful to the guys who actually went
to the trouble of writing Giulia so
thank you very much thanks a lot David I
thought it was really interesting and I
think we probably have time for one or
two quick questions before we move on
sort of I I kind of have tentatively
started one last year but we only only
met once there are a number of us who
use it and we just haven't said I've
been quite busy and we haven't really
gotten around to meeting again but we
are here when you say it has a data
frame does it have the same interface as
the Python the pandas dataframe what was
it different it's different but the guys
who wrote it would have previously used
pandas so there's huge overlap I would
have to look up I haven't used data
frames with Julia not not for my own
core research so I can't I can't say for
certain okay one more and then we move
on
I regarding sharing data frames between
Python and Julia because I think today
morning in the keynotes
it was shown how you could share data
friends between R and Python is also
possible in Julia oh it's definitely
possible yeah you have full access to
the Python so it to what any code you
call so you've access to all of the
Python objects directly from Julia
through the interface that they wrote so
yeah it's completely possible I don't I
don't use I haven't used data frames in
over two years so it's that's how long
I've been using Julia okay I would say
thank you again David thank you